[Musique]
c'est un instrument ancestral
en france rares sont ceux qui manient la
flûte de pan avec autant de passion que
georges schmit on voit toujours la frite
de pain à travers le folklore d'amérique
du sud et d'europe centrale
moi j'ai décidé il ya très longtemps du
sein des dépoussiérer un petit peu cet
instrument qui est millénaire en
adaptant justement de la musique
classique ou en proposant une musique
ces concerts ont lieu essentiellement
dans les églises pour une meilleure
acoustique mais pas seulement
le flûtiste se produit régulièrement
avec un organiste
c'est très complémentaire 1 vraiment
c'est un instrument c'est à peu près le
même somme sauf que le la flûte de pan à
des sons beaucoup plus aiguë que l'orgue
je connais georges depuis une
non et depuis nous ne nous quittons plus
c'est un artiste effectivement qu'on
peut difficilement et ton mieux mettre
dans une case et ça c'est parfait c'est
sans doute pour ça que nous entendons
aussi bien un centre de l'orgue la foule
de points est composé de la même manière
un ensemble de tuyaux sonore assemblés
les uns avec les autres et c'est chez
lui que georges fabrique ses protégés
collet maastricht y penser une vingtaine
d'heures est nécessaire pour concevoir
une flûte il réalise lui-même chaque
étape un savoir-faire désormais reconnu
ennio morricone ou encore hugues aufray
possède chez eux un de ses modèles un
instrument qu'il a également su faire
évoluer
il est l'inventeur de la flûte de pan
accordables grâce à un système de piston
j'ai fait un piquetage donc ça permet
donne d'attraper donc à l'intérieur de
chaque tube ensuite attrapé le piston
qui permet de le tirer ou de pousser le
piston
voilà c'est un temps considérable que je
gagne à chaque concert que je fais dans
les églises
puisque aucun org faut savoir qu'aucun
or il est accordé la même façon depuis
les années 80 ses albums neuf disques
d'or et des tournées mondiales
une carrière qui n'est pas prête de
s'arrêter georges enregistre
actuellement son 17e album consacré à la
musique celtique
[Musique]
m
[Rires]
à la fin de mes concerts je rajoutais
toujours 2 3 musique celtique et j'ai vu
que les spectateurs est absolument
enthousiasmé par ce genre de musique
on peut tous exprimés fait la joie la
gaieté la tristesse le rythme et en
temps ça fait voyager 1 et pour
l'accompagner jean charles beer aux
ingénieurs du son installé à javené ses
origines bretonnes ont aidé à capter les
envies de georges
mais il voit déjà plus loin ce serait de
l'emmener dans des univers plus
électronique maintenant pour aller dans
un truc un petit peu hors temps de
rentrer dans une dent dans le
contemporain dans le dur pas encore de
date de sortie prévue mais d'autres
concerts de georges schmit sont à venir
pour patienter des extraits sont mises
en ligne sur son site internet
[Musique]